traffic is moving now on the u.s 95
northwest to downtown after a fuel
tanker spilled over both lanes closed
cleanup caused all sorts of delays joe
mueller is live with how it looks right
now joe
yeah well traveling around the 95 in
this area was a bit of a nightmare
earlier today well into the afternoon
i'll give you a live look here at the 95
just at valley view boulevard you're
taking a live look at cars moving once
again here but the last crews are
cleaning this all up just left here
about 20 minutes ago but both
directions are now reopened this all
happened before five this morning when a
bmw and truck carrying thousands of
gallons of fuel crashed on the
northbound side of the 95 north of the
valley view exit around 100 gallons of
fuel spilled the rest of the gas had to
be transferred to another tanker truck
crews then flipped the tanker and towed
it away which took several crews and
hours luckily no one was hospitalized or
suffered major injuries people were
waiting hours to just get a few miles in
this area
i was trying to get on the 95 to come to
the meadows mall and they had it blocked
off the highway patrol said keep going
people are driving more crazy on the
streets because they're trying to hurry
up and get like to work to school
it makes it harder on traffic outside of
the freeway
the northbound lanes were closed until
about two o'clock this afternoon now
back out here live again crews just left
the valley view boulevard just under
there just about 20 minutes ago and open
up that final lane so all traffic is
moving once again people out here
stopping by saying they're happy that
traffic is moving again especially now
when people are just getting off work
reporting live here at valley view
boulevard in the 95. joe muller news now